die militärmusiker des bundesheeres
garantieren seit jeher für qualitätvolle
dargebotene musik
bei nationalen oder internationalen
einsätzen wird musik auf höchstem niveau
vermittelt
vom solo trompeter über kleine ensembles
bis zum großen blasorchester überzeugt
die österreichische militärmusik durch
vielfalt im repertoire
perfekt inszenierte auftritte und hohe
musikalität
großveranstaltungen wie das jährlich
stattfindende militärmusikfestival sind
die geeignete bühne für auftritte der
militärmusik
bis zu 10.000 zuhörer verfolgen gebannt
die darbietungen
hmm
auch im zusammenspiel mit internationale
musikgruppen beweisen die militärmusiker
außerordentliches feingefühl
als ausdruck sichtbarer spielfreude
glänzen die militärmusik bei bällen mit
bigband combo und ballack ist und bilden
so traditionell einen fixen bestandteil
der ballsaison
die militärmusik der beruf als berufung
für österreich